Solar panels, stretching as far as the eye can see.
China wants to become the world's leading producer of solar energy...
...and is investing massively in solar panels...
...that now covers huge swathes of desert.
The nation is the biggest market for solar energy in the world...
...and home to most of the largest panel manufacturers.
When completed, the Gao Tai solar park will cover 319 square kilometers.
That's three times the size of Paris or 80,000 panels per square kilometer.
This used to be the Gobi Desert.
There was nothing here,...
...just stones and wind.
The earth wasn't arable.
It wasn't profitable,...
...but now it's a treasure.
A nearby coal factory is spewing dark smoke.
China knows its dependency on coal is no longer viable.
Its towns are suffocating; pressure from the public opinion is growing...
...and China has considerable natural assets...
...according to the head of this solar energy plant.
It's not always like this.
We have more than 280 days of sunshine a year.
Winters are very cold,...
...but associated with a clear blue sky, this produces increased efficiency.
Moreover, solar panels require very little maintenance...
...and have a lifetime expectancy of around 25 years.
Problem is that, here in the desert, there is little need for electricity.
It therefore needs to be transported to China's industrial regions.
And that's where the problem lies.
The solar park has grown faster than China's infrastructure.
Today, the plant only runs at half its capacity.